[Musik]
bismarck gast ist die blm unix frei also
ich komme mir nichts und deswegen würde
ich an ihrer stelle auch nicht kommen
zweitens wenn werden wir uns vielleicht
alle ja sowieso erholen müssen weil
unser thema heute antike indien ist und
ich habe ein einrad was ich immer an
studenten geld doktor studenten so wenn
sie vortragen müssen
ich sage immer mit entschuldigungen
anfangen soll
selbstbewusst und kraftvoll in jede
vorlesung in jedem vortrag geben
in diesem fall möchte ich sie wirklich
warnen dass es nicht mein spezialgebiet
ich kann keinen sanskrit und bin
überhaupt kein forscher für indische
philosophie und man könnte vielleicht
sogar nein das ich dass das ziemlich
gewagt ist dass ich überhaupt eine
sitzung in dieser vorlesung frei antiken
indien widmen
allerdings habe ich mehr die ausreden
erstens ich finde es bedauerlich dass
antik indien immer vernachlässigt von
philosophiehistoriker ich weiß nicht ob
ich gekommen bin ob irgendein seminar
oder sonst was in der fakultät über
indische philosophie geboten wurde
aber ich denke wahrscheinlich nichts
waren hier natürlich eine institut für
biologie mit dynamite übrigens einer
sehr sehr guten bibliothek aber uns
selbst die philosophie bibliothek hat
viele bücher über indische philosophie
wie ich entdeckt habe
aber
wir haben kein experte für indische ist
wie in der philosophie qualität und von
daher bin ich praktisch das beste was im
angebot ist also wenn ich das nicht
mache dann wird es niemand machen kurz
autobiografisch der fluss indus fluss
wie als ich noch in london war war ich
einmal ich bin einmal unschuldig durch
die departemente gegangen und dann ist
ein kollege von mir zu mir gekommen und
hat gesagt
peter ich freue mich zu sehen wenn ich
hatte schon ein schlechtes gefühl weil
er zuständig war frei die examen und ich
wusste dass er gerade bei war kiefer zu
organisieren weil die examen die hier
hat halt gehalten haben und daher gesagt
der prüfer für ähnliche philosophie ist
krank wir suchen jemanden der das machen
kann ja gesagt der glocke hat gesagt du
machst aber doch nicht die westliche
philosophie ja gesagt ich mach
islamische philosophie
das ist also es fängt auch mit ihr an
da nicht aus und sagt na ja jemand muss
machen ihr glück und ihr habt
tatsächlich ich weiß ja auch wie das
aufnehmen sollen falls die denkmal
damals geschah und was interessant war
übrigens das hat nichts mit thema zu tun
aber es geht trotzdem interessant in
england ist es so dass alle examen
zweimal geprüft werden
blind also ich als prüfer die noten
vergeben noten und der andere prüfer
auch in diesem fall werde weil der
zweite profi doch experte für angeles
wie wir haben gedacht gott sei dank weil
ich werde einfach seine noten übertragen
und wir werden meine noten wegschmeißen
also ich bin da zu sein
formell mitgeteilt und wir hatten genau
die gleichen noten was und es waren so
35 examen es war unglaublich ohne dass
ich das wusste und daran habe ich
erkannt man kann philosophie examen
prüfen
dadurch dass man so sagen schaut ob das
sinn macht und will es auch interessant
ist ist egal was der stoff ist
also jahrelang habe ich nichts über
indische philosophie gewusst bis auf das
was sich aus diesen examen gelernt habe
was nicht viel war
und dann habe ich diesen podcast
angefangen das habe ich schon erwähnt
ist für frau sowie podcasts und der
spruch also das motto des partners ist
geschichte philosophie beladenen glocken
und fast von anfang an haben dann höre
geschrieben oder kommentare auf der
website gelassen
wie können sie sagen dass sie die
geschichte und das vieh oder anders
machen wenn es die indische philosophie
nicht abdecken
ja gesagt ja schon gut aber kenne ich
überhaupt nicht aus dass kann ich mich
machen aber die haben gesagt praktisch
macht trotzdem
und dann habe ich sowieso andere themen
abgedeckt die mir auch völlig unbekannt
war zum beispiel spätantike christliche
für das wie zum beispiel alles was ich
letzte woche über die christliche
philosophie askese und und marina und
als dass das weiß ich nur weil die
parkas dazu geschrieben hat wir sind das
vielleicht zu viel aber ich glaube ich
zu meinen dass das was ich gesagt habe
war ist wegen des vaters und dann dachte
ich also wenn ich sowieso dabei bin
sozusagen haus erhalten einen meiner
kompetenz vorzugehen leitung nicht
indien und noch wichtiger ich habe einen
co autor gefunden generiert und der ist
ein führender experte für indische
philosophie also wir machen das zusammen
und es gibt sogar eine folge die vor ein
paar wochen erschienen ist über frauen
in antiken indien
also das ist was sie als schön es wäre
wenn wir eine längere version dieser
podcast folge wenn sie das auch hören
wollen dass das bei der website zu
finden
also zuerst ich gehe davon aus dass gibt
es übrigens jemanden hier der experte
für indische philosophie ist der
vielleicht lieber die vor den vortrag
halten will
nein okay dann werd ichs machen und ich
werde davon ausgehen dass sie so gut wie
nichts wissen dass du sie wissen wo in
den ist aber mehr nichts
das war mehr oder weniger mein zustand
am anfang und im voraus möchte ich sagen
und wenden wenn sie nur eines eines
merken von dieser vorlesung was sie
merken sollen ist indische börse wie ist
unglaublich interessant
alles kann wird das kann wirklich mit
kritischen philosophisch mit antiker
griechischen philosophie konkurrieren
für die philosophie interesse und ist es
wirklich für mich verblüffend und
unerklärlich dass dies nichts also nicht
unerklärlich ist eigentlich fast zu
denken dass das passieren würde sind
materials also auf sanskrit was die
meisten nicht lesen können nicht lesen
können wir mit in europa und nordamerika
aber selbst ohne salz mitlesen zu können
es gibt genügend übersetzungen studien
usw
da kann man sehr schnell erkennen
das ist eine sehr sehr raffinierte
komplizierte tiefe philosophische
tradition mit viele in vielen
traditionen viele philosophische
richtungen
und wenn ich versuchen würde nur die
höhepunkte der indischen klotz wie ich
selbst in den ersten paar tausend in den
ersten 1000 jahren
ich würde wäre das semester brauchen das
zu tun es ist wirklich sehr sehr
beeindruckend ich hatte irgendwie die
erwartung im voraus das ist wirklich
interessant ist aber es ist noch viel
interessanter als ich dachte zu sein
also ich würde natürlich die die podcast
serie darüber empfehlen wenn sie mehr
wollen
ganz also jetzt ganz ganz grob um die
situation zu verstehen ist es hilfreich
eine sehr oberflächliche differenzierung
zu machen gleich von anfang an
und das fängt schon in der antiken
indien also in indien hin seit von roma
platon aristoteles und so weiter und das
ist vielleicht eine differenzierung
gesagt zwischen zwei grobe gruppen
jeweils also beide gruppen enthalten
mehrere untergruppen es werde es vorerst
ist wer das vorlesen auf einer seite
haben wir die wendische tradition wird
oft die hindu tradition genannt oder
hinduismus oder vielleicht vor
hinduismus und die im voraus so soll man
diesen ausdruck nur mit vorsicht
benutzen hinduismus ist kein wort was in
der antike benutzt wurde und kann sehr
leicht die tatsächliche abdecken dass
diese schulen visionen die auf dieser
seite fallen sehr unterschiedlich sind
und sehr viele und meinungsunterschiede
hatten gegeneinander
also sieht die sache sein dass sich
nicht unbedingt als eine einheitliche
tradition wie sie sehen werden in kürze
diese philosophische schulen die auf
dieser seite sind die die würde auch oft
gesplittet hinunter untergruppen also
das könnte man vielleicht mit der
situation in der antike vergleichen
es gibt zum beispiel nicht nur
hellenistische philosophie es gibt auch
die story kann die skeptiker und und die
korea und die argumentieren
gegeneinander
innerhalb des rassismus gibt es
meinungsunterschiede usw
okay was diese diese seite
charakterisiert ist hier irgendein
gefühl dass die weder ist eine gewisse
autorität besitzen was sind die webers
die weder sind hd gehören zu den
ältesten texten die wir haben manche
davon mindestens zum beispiel die der
erste direkt wieder ist solch eine älter
als homer und diese texte sind wie die
haben sehr unterschiedliche inhalte aber
auffällig ist dass sie sehr viel über
ritual sprechen
das ist damit zur geburt verbunden was
sie wahrscheinlich schon über indische
kultur ist nämlich diese schichten diese
geschichten die brachen die shuttles und
ja dann zwei weitere schichten also ganz
unten haben wir die chance dies sind
mehr oder weniger wie sklaven und die
dritte klasse ist mehr wie handels
männer und hier wichtigsten die brothers
und die shuttles sind die kriegs männer
und auch die könige gehören dazu und sie
und die werden die die haben sie die
arbeiten sozusagen mit den drachmen
zusammen
dadurch dass die brachen die ritual
ausführte im namen des mannes und der
frau auch also das heißt dass das
übrigens die alle drei klassen also alle
also die den shooter ist dürfen an
dieser edition virtual teilnehmen
die wälder sind das ist ein sehr
komplizierter textkorpus aus vier
schichten die ursprüngliche wewers und
es ist
das ist ein bisschen verwirrend manchmal
wenn man das wort weder benutzt meint
man damit neugierig ursprüngliche texte
und manchmal meint man haut die
kommentare oder später die texte die das
erläutern und zu diesem dieser größeren
gruppe der welten gehören die berühmte
kubanische aden die japanischen sind
wahrscheinlich die erste texte der aus
antiken indien die sicherlich als oder
die sozusagen auffällig philosophisch
sind nicht immer es gibt auch zum
beispiel beratung über familienleben es
gibt viele beschreibungen der ritual es
gibt auslegung der ursprünglichen weder
und so weiter und so fort
aber dann gibt es immer wieder passagen
die sehr auffällig für das wissen und
die wir werden ein paar davon später
lesen
es gibt übrigens am digitalen lesen
dritter in der vorlesung lädt ab
vorlesen werde sehr passend ich werde
eine vorlesung vor lesen sie die sind
auf der website verfügbar
auf deutsch sogar also in dieser
übersetzung und dann gibt es noch
mehrere texte zu dieser woche über die
andere passagen die ich besprechen werde
die im palisaden die auch die aleviten
würden über jahrhunderte geschrieben
und deswegen kann man nicht pauschal
sagen die und panisch aden lernen das
oder jenes haben diese ansicht die haben
unterschiedliche ansichten da kommen
viele viele figuren vor philosophen
brach - könige und so weiter und so fort
also dass die sind sehr komplizierte
texte und selbst innerhalb einer partie
schadet es zb in dem japanischen wovon
ich vorlesen werde gibt es
wahrscheinlich schichten wo das nach und
nach geschrieben würden würde über
mehrere
hunderte flights und natürlich von
vielen verschiedenen halten und das ist
typisch für auch andere texte in dieser
situation sehr berühmt sind die zwei
große was ist die nerven und dazu gehört
die macher baratta das ist vielleicht
mit homer zu begleichen aber viel viel
viel länger als roma ich glaube ich habe
irgendwo gelesen dass die macher baratta
zehnmal so lang ist wie beide haben
zusammen aber es ist also das ist so ein
text wo man eine übersetzung aus der
schub aus der buch unternimmt dann denkt
man kann nicht glauben wie lang des sc
und dann schaut man es sieht man dass
das nur auszüge ist es ist verblüffend
und dann hören auch in der mache partei
gibt es immer wieder passagen die
vielleicht philosophische relevant sind
die berühmteste passage ist die bagger
guitar lied des herrn wo wie viel soll
ich darüber sagen also ich werde später
was über die philosophische inhalte der
guitar sagen habe nur grob so erkennen
was das ist für einen text es gibt ein
hauptheld in der marbacher ist
vielleicht ähnlich wie achilles und der
hat der hat einen wagen leiter namens
krishna und die macher walther geht
darum dass innerhalb einer familie in
größe von katjas also von kriegs männern
nicht einen großen ein großer krieg auf
auf aus und als schüler ist einer unter
den mächtigsten helden auf der guten
seite
und die sind alle gerade dabei große
schlacht zu führen und eine andere
umzubringen
und das wird auch so katastrophal so da
werden tausende sterben in dem kriege
und gleich vor dem anfang jänner das ja
doch nicht kämpfen will es noch mal
erinnert dass anna schell ist der als
sich zurückzieht und er stehst du sagen
in seinem wagen bleiben und sagte nein
ich will nicht und dann anspringt
krishna zu ihnen und endlos sich als
gott uns erklärt warum hat warum all
jener doch kämpfen soll nun ein für
entfaltet faktisch eine theorie des
handelns was war sehr philosophisch ist
kombiniert philosophie mit religiöser
ansätze ist natürlich gehört zu den
größten texten der geschichte der
weltreligion war es auch sehr
philosophisch und ich werde später mehr
darüber sagen okay dann gibt es andere
texte zum beispiel gesetz bücher zum
beispiel die gesetze - wovon ich bald
zitieren werde und andere bücher über
damals die sogenannte diamond race und
oder damals und andere bücher über
gesetze vielleicht kann man auch so
dieser gruppe werke über politische
philosophie zählen zb die art des astra
was auch sehr alt ist von einem
angeblich von einem visier nahmen scout
elia geschieden und das ist unter
anderem ein text über über politische
theorie wird manchmal mit machiavelli
verglichen weil er sehr viele beratung
dem könig anbietet wie man effektiv
einen staat führen kann regieren kann
und das und das ist alle also dass auch
philosophisch dann gibt es den könig
ashoka ein könig der buddhist geworden
ist und der viele inschriften überall in
indien hinterlassen hat mit ethische und
politische und vor wie genetische
botschaft an seine bevölkerung und das
ist alles bevor wir die eigentliche
philosophie erreichen also sozusagen
antike antike indien und ungefähr geht
auch in dieser zeit wo chocolate hat
auch sehr schwierig sie datieren kommen
die erste superstars oder vielleicht zu
tun aber es sind sehr normalerweise sehr
kurze sätze und sehr schwierig zu
verstehen
zb so was die das wahre ich ist der wind
oder sowas noch schwieriger zu verstehen
und die kommen nacheinander oft in
keiner erkennbaren reihenfolge und eine
sammlung davon wird auch zu tragen an zb
kamasutra ist die story ist das wird was
pro von halle gehört haben dass ist zu
tag über lust oder freude und hier haben
wir mehrere schulen die traditionsgemäß
als sechs hauptschulen der des
hinduismus definiert wurden
wie man sowie scania
usw
und in jedem fast jeden fall gibt es
dann ein ursprünglichen text der
maßgebliches für die gleich für die
ganze situation in form einer so zum
beispiel die na ja super oder yoga store
ist dann die die ein text worauf die
ganze tradition dann reagiert reagiert
manchmal war so grundlegend diese
soziales zu haben dass in einem fall gab
es eine schule ohne eine zutat
und deswegen hat jemand nach
jahrhunderte eine super geschrieben
damit sie auch eine sozial hatten hat
dieses sind sehr wie gesagt sehr
schwierig zu verstehen und man spürt
sehr stark ein bedarf für kommentar und
das zu erläutern und erklären also was
eigentlich los ist
es scheint sogar so sein dass die sozis
manchmal mit einem kommentar erschienen
sind und auf jeden fall in jedem in
jedem fall mehr oder weniger in jedem
für jede schule gibt es eine
überschwängliche sutter und dann einen
kommentar darauf dass ja das könnte man
vielleicht auch mit antiken positiv
vergleichen wo wir zum beispiel hat es
dort ließ haben
sehr prägnant sehr schwierig zu lesen
sei schwierig zu verstehen und dann
haben wir kommentare in der spätantike
aber mehr so prägnant also etwa die
soziales kurze und prägnante sind als
alles dort ließ die die lesen sich
eigentlich nicht als texte sondern mehr
wie aphorismen sammlungen und die basis
kommen dann rein und sagen okay erstens
erkläre ich wie der text organisiert
würde dann die hauptthemen dann
erläutere ich jedes jedes ist jedes
aphorismen jedes uta und erkläre die
gedanken dahinter die situation
sozusagen rein philosophisch zum
beispiel eine schule sind die mensa und
das eine schule der wege städtischen
exegese allerdings gibt es viele viele
philosophische probleme die dann
auftauchen zb sie wollen erklären warum
man warum man die aktualität der weder
anerkennen muss und dann kommen sie
darauf so erklären warum man überhaupt
irgendetwas glauben soll
und dann machen sie etwas molo gi oder
aber oder vedanta ist eine die
erweiterung der meisterschule und die
behandeln form die japanischen und dann
kommen sie darauf die philosophische
ansätze in den fahrschein zu erklären
und diese schulen dann laufen dann für
jahrtausende eigentlich weiter das ist
alles ein bisschen lehre für uns also
dass man das wort hinduismus wie gesagt
ist irgendwas auch helfend ist dass
diese sechs schulen oft als orthodox
beschrieben werden was zwei probleme mit
sich bringt ersten sogenannten sollte
man sagen würde dass die gute seite in
die schlechte seite war heute das heißt
natürlich richtig glauben
und das so sagen das ist wenn man alles
aus der hindurch handy perspektive
definiert das ist ein problem aber wie
gesagt diese andere problem ist dass
diese schulen dass sie miteinander sehr
viel gestritten haben
und dann hat jede schule mehr oder
weniger ist aufgesplittet zb man so gibt
es eine eine ausschüttung im siebten
jahrhundert wo wir dann zwei
verschiedenen schulen haben oder 3
verloren
vedanta auch als eine art monster sein
könnte also sehr kompliziert von außen
betrachtet ist es kaum zu bewältigen
also wenn man eine liste von schulen und
philosophen sieht das ist wirklich sehr
sehr imposant also ist es grob eine
seite grobe die andere seite sind die
kritiker der vedischen kultur
am bekanntesten sind die buddhisten
jahre habe es gibt dann andere
traditionen die in diese richtung
tendieren vor allem zwei andere schulen
die auch als schwarm aller bewegungen
genannt werden kann
also das sind reaktionen wo die gelehrt
haben dass man heute schon von dem
diesseitigen leben befreien kann durch
magna was dass es ein ausdruck den wir
später begegnen werden also die und was
hier die idee ist was wollten was wollte
man ursprünglich mit ritual erreichen
verschiedene sachen zum beispiel man
könnte ihre durch ritual eine größere
familie haben reichtum mehr werden
politische macht gesundheit der kinder
kriegen und solche sachen
aber was man auch erreichen konnte war
natürlich ein besseres nächste leben und
oft wird ritual als eine methode
vorgestellt dass er guten glück
sozusagen in den nächsten leben zu haben
und dagegen haben diese drei gruppen die
buddhisten die aktiver kreis und djs
vorgeschlagen dass wir diese
immer wieder wiedergeboren zu werden
dass wir das entkommen können und sollen
ganz radikal sind die archive
eine ausgestorbene schule oder religiöse
bewegung die dann nichts bis in die zeit
der suptras überlebt hatte und die haben
also ihre theorie war dass man zuerst
all die schlechte karma die man
aufgebaut hat während des lebens dann
irgendwie abschaffen soll und dann wenn
man das erreicht hat sollte man also wo
man sozusagen überhaupt keine kammer hat
gut oder schlecht war kramer ist
praktisch das was das nächste leben dann
verursacht
nachdem man alle kammer ab geschaffen
hat sondern einfach stillstehen stehen
bleiben bis man stirbt
und wenn man das erreicht ist man wird
man befreit die die blödesten und denn
es war nicht so radikal
nun haben auch nicht vorgestellt haben
eigentlich nichts für die meiste
verfolger dieser traditionen
vorgeschlagen dass sie tatsächlich
befreit werden können
aber die haben ethische vor allem
ethische lehre vertreten womit man
vermeiden kannte schlechte karma zu sich
zu ziehen
und vor allem sollten sie die lernen von
den begründete der zweite aktionen
natürlich bitter für buddhismus folgen
damit man halt besser lebt sehr gutes
beispiel dass djs sehr stark gegen
gewalt waren wurden keine gewalt ausüben
und waren nicht nur vegetarier sondern
haben es also zu
manche haben sogar vermieden zb mit
feuer oder vorher zu bauen falls sie
insekten bringen
es gibt bilder von
von jana manche sehen wo sie masken
tragen und mit einem besen durch die
straße gehen und vorsichtig alle kleine
fischer aus dem weg schieben damit sie
nicht drauftreten und so oder so sollen
zb also das mag ich sehr gut sie sollen
nichts ändern nichts am abendessen oder
nicht in der nacht essen falls sie in
sekte aus für sie in essen weil es ist
natürlich ohne elektrisches licht ist es
ein gefallen wahrscheinlich soll niemand
in der nacht essen wenn man das überlegt
ja ok auf jeden fall als es gibt sehr
interessante ethische lehre auf dieser
seite
aber das was sozusagen grob wichtig ist
ist dass sie alle kritiker waren gegen
die vedischen tradition zum beispiel
haben sie mich zum beispiel aber sehr
sein zahl haben sie behauptet dass
weniger ritual nichts das erreichen kann
was sie verspricht und dass diese ganze
macht beziehungen zwischen den brachen
drachens und in kroatien irgendwie
entdeckte das ist einfach nicht nichts
bringt was man trotzdem was man etwas
dessen machen soll ist das alles
verlassen und im besten fall als manch
leben oder nonne verfahren das werden
wir dann sehen
ich werde übrigens irgendwann zu die
frauen kommen aber ich dachte es wäre
gut wenn sie in dessen hintergrund haben
sie sieht sie haben diese ganze
tradition abgelehnt haben also die ganze
radikale davon haben
unter sich in einer gemeinde gelebt als
manche also matt monastische gemeinde
und es gab deutliche gemeinden und
männliche es gibt natürlich auch texte
über buddhismus zum beispiel gibt es in
der party sprache gab es viele viele
texte über bruder was er gesagt hat was
er gelernt hat was er getan hat es gibt
viele legenden über ihn und so weiter
und das ist dann maßgeblich für die
spätere station wo ähnlich mit janis
muss die parkhäuser nicht nur
interessantes das ist eine sozusagen
nichts orthodox schule die nichts mit
diesen preis zu tun hat ist eine
materialistische schule mehr oder
weniger die dann auch eines zu zur hacks
und mit kommentaren so könnte man was
auf dieser seite tun vom gestalt her
aber es sind so weit weg von der lehre
dieser seite dass man die ja wacker
schule oft als hetero dogs definiert
aber das ist wirklich nichts mit diesen
drei schwimmern bewegungen zu
vergleichen
also chronologisch sind wir hier
zwischen also eigentlich mehr oder
weniger in der gleichen zeit was wir
schon in der vorlesung in europa
abgedeckt haben
weil das sind also die um panischen
bruder usw
die erste james die sind 65 die vierte
jahrhundert vor christus
die tauchen von flex dritte viertel
jahrhundert vor christus bis dritten
jahrhundert nach christus dann kommen
die basis und die weitere entwicklung
dieser schulen für sich fort bis in die
80 jahrhundert und in dieser zeit
kommt eine interessante entwicklung die
ich nicht ganz gut verstehe ich noch
mindestens bis her dass buddhismus mehr
oder weniger indien ausgestorben ist und
dann natürlich nach china und in andere
asiatische länder dann um gewandert ist
aber es ist an der zeit die ich schon
geschrieben habe ist diese kritik der
hindu region sehr bestimmend für die
ganze philosophie situation war eben
diese schulen versuchen skeptische
kritik von den buddhisten und den james
zu widerlegen also versuchen um zum
beispiel zu zeigen dass man das dass die
braven wissen besitzen was sehr wichtig
ist und was gut begründet ist und die
buddhisten lehnen das ab und kritisieren
dass und kommen darauf sehr abstrakte
skeptische argumente zu benutzen zum
beispiel also oft argumente die wir auch
in der späten spätantiken skeptizismus
finden vielleicht sollte ich mal kurz
erwähnen weil sonst nichts sonst wird
die sonst jemanden fragen
es gibt immer die frage ob griechische
philosophie und oder antipasti und
antiken dichters wie irgendwie
miteinander zu tun hatten und meine
antwort darauf ist dass es sehr unklar
ist
möglich ist es auf jeden fall also rein
susan historisch denn der grieche
spreche die könige und gesellschaften in
zentralasien hatten haben nach alexander
der große und es gibt sogar gleiche
schwächen die könige die macht in
nordindien ausgeübt haben
und das sehr früh also im vierten
jahrhundert vor christus also und dann
gibt es auch zb griechische historiker
die in indien waren zurückgekommen sind
und haben darüber berichtet
also die die verbindungen sind da auf
jeden fall
ob wir aber wirklich einfluss von
philosophischen texten von sanskrit aus
sanskrit irgendwie an griechische texte
haben oder umgekehrt ist meiner meinung
nach relativ fraglich
also ich würde sagen dass wir sehr oft
ähnliche themen haben sogar ähnliche
argumente aber wirklich das zustand
diese passage basiert sich irgendwie auf
diese passage in denen panne schaden
oder in diese in jener sutra oder was
auch immer
das ist wirklich schwer zu sagen und ich
persönlich bin ich in eine buddhistische
richtung und bin eher skeptisch
aber das würden wir auch dann später in
dem in der podcast serie absackten
vielleicht ergibt dann meine meinung
ändern
ok so das ist der grobe hintergrund
jetzt wage ich zu fragen ob jemand
fragen hat also natürlich könnte man
tausende fragen haben aber wie kann
nicht versprechen dass ich die antwort
gewesen wäre
[Musik]
und natürlich schon
aber einfach heißen
dies muss auch also es gibt natürlich
jetzt gibt auch natürlich die frage wo
zusagen region aufhört und flüsse wieder
anfängt
klar gibt es immer also bereit bei
christentum islam gibt es dieses problem
auf
und auch ob und inwiefern man sowas wie
buddhismus oder janis mossoro shanteau
oder sowas als religion also was will
man damit sagen ja das ist problematisch
aber bei hinduismus ist weiter
problematisch dass das kein ausdruck ist
was damals existiert hat also mein punkt
war dass das ist wirklich im nachhinein
reininterpretiert dann tourismus ist
also hinter indien also das was wir also
man sagt ja indische religion das ist
hinduismus und die tatsache dass wir
heute haben ist heutzutage leute haben
die sich als hindus definieren
das ist dass es nicht unbedingt erfüllen
was sie natürlich irgendwie irre
geschichte zurück für die wähler ist und
diese handel zurückführen würden aber
ich wollte nur sagen das ist gefährlich
und man soll
aber das weiß ich glaube das kommt viel
später oder kritisch da kann ich mir das
okay fand erfragen oder besser
feststellungen regierungen
es wäre auch schön dass sie was ihnen
etwas einfällt können sie später fragen
ok jetzt frauen ich hab was die halte
derzeit schon gespart wird
ich möchte ich würde sehr gerne sagen
paar gute nachricht die lage der frauen
in antiken in der nur viel viel besser
als in antiken europa aber das wort
nicht der fall
die ansichten über fragen waren
eigentlich ähnlich zu dem was wir in der
griechischen region finden und der
japanischen tradition also typisch ist
ein zitat aus einem gesetzbuch manus ich
habe eine englische übersetzung her auf
dem handy eine elf aus sollten nicht
unabhängig machen sogar in ihrem eigenen
haus auch wenn ihr mann ihr ehemann
nicht brav ist und zufällig ist lustig
nachzugehen
auch wenn gar nichts für ihn spricht
jugendliche ehefrau immer ihn als ein
gott worship
wer also dass das ist nicht super
andererseits gibt es einmal muss schon
sagen es gibt auch passagen die man
sogar aus diesem gleichen text zitieren
könnte die viel besser sind die frauen
mehr auf nicht gleich lange vielleicht
aber die frauen eine wichtige rolle zum
beispiel in der ritual zu schreiben und
das ist auch typisch dass selbst in
einem text wir verschiedene ansichten
meinungen haben denn sie wie gesagt über
längere zeit von vielen autoren
geschrieben würden also vielleicht sind
marke von den halter frauenfeindlich
manche er nichts
also ja das ist diese kasten oder
schichten ja genau das wollte ich gerade
sagen dass wir vielleicht ein
grundlegendes problem alles was wir in
diesen gesetzbüchern finden ist eine
sehr weit verbreitete idee die da
genannt wird
und da mal kann verschiedene sachen
bedeuten aber eine bedeutung ist
praktisch die dienste die man in diesem
leben leisten muss also jeder hat seine
aufgabe zu erfüllen
die bei platon in der polit er übrigens
jeder hat seine aufgabe und es kommt
darauf an zu welcher schicht mann gehört
die man daneben soll zum beispiel ein
schuldner hat nicht die aufgabe zu
erklären er hat die schuld die aufgabe
regiert zu werden oder zu dienen
das ist übrigens noch was was sehr oft
übertrieben wird wenn man geschichte
über die gier handy liest man würde den
eindruck haben dass jeder in antiken
indien dauernd dran gedacht hat in
welcher kaste bin ich also in welcher
schicht
es war wahrscheinlich viel komplizierter
als das und zb familien gruppen und
geografische gruppen oder abteilungen
von bestimmten mindestens so wichtig für
identität aber trotzdem vor allem diesen
büchern die ethik bestreiten wird diese
idee der damals sehr stark betont dass
jeder seine aufgabe hat und das geht
nicht nur für diese schichten sondern
auch für frauen also frauen als frauen
haben eine dame und die dame ist
eigentlich zu heiraten kinder zu kriegen
und dem ehemann zu bedienen also von
susanne fleck sogar stärkere irgendwie
als in antiken europa gibt es 1 1 ein
grund warum frauen nur zu sagen in dem
die innerhalb einer sehr begrenzten zone
arbeiten können weil sie eben von dame
eingeschränkt werden
natürlich ist jede frau mehr als eine
frau sie ist auch aus einer bestimmten
familie religion usw
oder man könnte das auch mit den kasten
kombinieren zum beispiel eine kiste ja
frau ist ganz anders als eine strafraum
und es gibt auch dramatische klinische
frauen also die ehefrauen von brachmann
christa also das ist nicht also alle
frauen sozusagen gleichrangig sind das
ist überhaupt nicht der fall und zum
beispiel in katar wird sehr oft
katja ist dieser der diese politische
diese politische diesen politischen text
geschrieben hat die ad astra
als besessen mit frauen also es gibt ein
langes kapitel über frauen und welche
gesetze man durchführen muss um frauen
zu reagieren und zum beispiel ist er
sehr differenziert also es gibt auch
einige frauen und niedrige frauen und
man muss sie anders reagieren zb wenn
man eine frau hat er also eines sklaven
vergewaltigt man muss dann dafür strafe
bezahlen aber bei weitem nicht so viel
wie wenn man eine reiche frau
vergewaltigt wieder schön
ok also es gibt also man könnte ich
könnte die restliche zeit hier stehen
und schlägt der zitate über frauen sind
hier genau wie für europa aber es gibt
auch schon ganz neue ansätze für bessere
möglichkeiten verfahren
erstens auf der bayerischen seite wie
ich schon erwähnt habe spielen die
frauen eine rolle in der in der
vedischen ritual
es gibt ritualen die nur baltic gültig
sind wenn der schattenmann von seiner
ehefrau begleitet wird also sie muss da
sein damit die ritual dann erfolgreich
ausgeführt wird trotzdem ist der ehemann
der haupt mitgeteilt also es ist
eigentlich seine also es ist eher der
das ausführt aber sie muss da sein und
deswegen ist wirklich sehr wichtig und
notwendig oder die beziehung ist
vielleicht wichtige notwendig für diese
kultur später indem man sie haben wir
die erklärung dass frauen an der ritual
mit beteiligt werden müssen oder dürfen
müssen weil ritual
dadurch erklärt ist dass wir alle
verlangen haben auf verschiedene ziele
und ritzmann es gibt mehr viele ziele
die wir nur durch ritual erreichen
können und frauen haben auch diese liste
und deswegen müssen auch die rituale
ausführen dürfen also interessant also
dass diese seite auf dieser seite gibt
es komplizierte sachen die man über die
drei schwarm aller schulformen die
buddhisten indigenas also wie frauen da
mitgeteilt worden
ganz im allgemeinen kann man sagen dass
die dieses romane bewegungen weil sie
eben die waren ausdrücklich gegen die
normale gesellschaftliche regeln also
sie haben das waren darauf zum beispiel
reiche leute die ausgestiegen sind
sozusagen aus dem leben eines eines
sogenannten haushaltes und an dann
gewollt ein armes leben geführt werden
nicht nochmal sehr stark an christliche
asketisches leben in der spätantike und
genau wie unter christen in der
spätantike wie wir mit marina oder
melania gesehen haben letzte woche genau
so haben wir die möglichkeit für
buddhistische oder jener frauen ihr
eingeschränktes leben als ehefrauen in
einem haushalt so entkommen
in dennis muss gibt es eine interessante
streit darüber ob frauen das machen
können überhaupt und das werde ich
gleich besprechen
dann noch ein paar überlegungen zur
theoretischen und textliche beziehungen
zu frauen also rein theoretisch könnte
man sich zum beispiel fragen was diese
kern theorie in der vedischen koalition
mit geschlechts zu tun hat also wenn man
tiefer geht mit nur einem ritual denkt
und man denkt an die philosophische
hintergründe
das war sehr stark und den partner
schaden vorkommt und das werden wir
später sehen in den zitaten die frau
lösen werde
ist die idee eines selbst der von ein
leben zu anderen überleben kann und
vielleicht hinter alle allen erfahrungen
steht
und natürlich gibt es auch die annahme
dass man zuerst man sein kann und dann
frau dann vielleicht wieder mal anrufen
oder vielleicht sogar menschen und dann
tiere königsklasse frau
und irgendwie ist das natürlich sehr
anfällig dafür frauenfeindlich als
gerecht zu werden zum beispiel die
können alles richtig machen wenn nichts
kommst du zurück das nächste mal als
eine frau also sie die hälfte von ihnen
werden bestraft jetzt für das was in
netzen neben gemacht haben aber andere
vielleicht sogar mehr als die hälfte die
mehrheit lesen weiblich also einerseits
gibt es das aber andererseits könnte man
überlegen also dieses dieser ist selbst
ist dieser satz wirklich männlich also
zum beispiel sind sie als frauen nach
dieser theorie männer die in einem
frauenkörper leben im moment dass wir
irgendwie komisch
also will man das sowieso ein logisch
durchdacht könnte man denken nein
die atmen also der selbst hat kein
geschlecht und das ist natürlich
interessant manchmal sehen wir texte die
in diese richtung neigen
neigen sie wirklich nichts dazu zum
beispiel gibt es einen text in der rede
situation wo wir hören dass susan der
der erste mensch geboren wird uns sofort
eine frau kreiert für ihn damit er dann
sich fortpflanzen kann also die idee
wäre dann anscheinend dass menschen
sozusagen von haus aus männer sind und
dass frauen irgendwie dann danach kommen
oder als begleitung kommen
aber es ist schwer zu sagen auch in der
vedischen tradition
ja ja ja ja man braucht beides natürlich
und das ist wie ich gesagt habe ich über
die werde jede tour zum beispiel dass
die ehefrau da sein muss aber sie ist
nicht die der hauptakteur aber sie ist
immer sie es notwendig dabei
also ich weiß wie man sich darüber hat
man werde sich darüber freuen soll aber
stimmt dann gibt es die frage ob text ob
texte die taxi die wir lesen von nur von
männern geschrieben würden und für
männer
und hier ist zum beispiel interessant
dass die macher baratta auszufüllen sagt
in einer passage dass das ein epos ist
für alle einschließlich arme leute und
frauen also sozusagen eine allgemeine
botschaft an die menschheit nicht nur
für eingeschlossene der gesellschaft der
die männlich ist
wir finden die idee die wie gesagt auf
dieser seite des frauen also manchmal
dass frauen locker erreichen können also
befreiung erreichen können manchmal
nicht in der berger warte kita steht
könnte man sich die frage ist dann ob
alle menschen fähig sind krishna zu
erreichen dass es praktisch was
vorgeschlagen wird wie später sagen
werde
und da in verschiedenen passagen haben
wir mal den vorschlag dass frauen das
nicht schaffen können und mal den
vorschlag dass sie das doch machen
können also in der ersten ersten fall
sagen sie dass sie ergebenheit an gott
zeigen können habe sie können nichts mit
sie können sich nicht mit krishna
identifizieren oder oder nur ein
gerissener denken wie männer können aber
in anderen passagen wird anscheinend
gesagt dass sie das doch machen können
noch mal muss man damit rechnen dass
verschiedene passagen vielleicht von
verschiedenen autoren geschrieben würden
mit verschiedenen meinungen
ok
sehr interessant ist die stellung der
frau innerhalb buddhismus
es wird die wissen wahrscheinlich dass
das juristisch in ordnung gibt nur nicht
nur gutes tun möchte mal soll übrigens
nie vergessen bei dieser bewegungen
es gibt sozusagen die ganz harten die
als manch hat sich monastisch leben
nonne oder mag und dann gibt es viel
mehr leute die anhänger der religion
oder der bewegung sind nun sie helfen
die mönche und erwerben dann gute kamera
oder hals susan smith spirituelle punkte
dafür dass sie die neu hier helfen zum
beispiel ich habe schon gesagt
james dürfen ja kein gewalt ausüben und
die möchte dürfen nicht einmal kochen
weil sie dann mit feuer arbeiten müssten
deswegen helfen die den mönchen die
laien dadurch dass sie essen kochen
dann geben sie das essen an die mönche
herrscht ende
das kommt auch im buddhismus vor also
wenn wir über die jüdische gemeinde
stärken
das kann man so sagen dass das ist
zweideutig man könnte damit mein alle
die buddhisten also alle die laien und
die möchte oder nur die st und das ist
dass es die monastische gemeinde und
angeblich und also bei anhalt die
geschichten geschichten über die den
bruder muss man wahrscheinlich angeblich
am anfang dahin hängen
angeblich war er zuerst sehr dagegen
frauen in die gemeinde akzeptieren und
hat würde dann praktisch überredet das
zu tun
ich glaube eine tante von ihm war der
erste anhänger die die erste anhänger
denn die rein dürfte in die st
und er hat gesagt mein dammer meine
lehre wird jetzt nur 500 jahre dauern
statt 1000 jahre was es was es ohne
frauen gemacht hätte sagt auch so was
wie wenn frauen in der gemeinde sind das
ist wie schimmel in einem feld in einem
getreidefeld
also das sind natürlich frauenfeindliche
einsätze innerhalb der des
buddhistischen korpus allerdings gibt es
auch buddhistische texte die viel
positiver über frauen sprechen
und hier ist das interessanteste
beispiel wahrscheinlich die der teddy
gatter und das ist ein text das kommt
erst viel später klopft ungefähr 200
nach christus aber die datierung ist
wieder schwierig denn es sind eigentlich
immer sehr schwierig der situation aber
auf jeden fall die jahrhunderte nach dem
buddha und wir haben hier zwei es sind
sozusagen zwillings texte der taylor
agatha und der teradata und ein text ist
für männliche möchte und der andere tags
ist für weibliche und in beiden fällen
haben wir geschichten über fromme
buddhisten und was sie erreicht haben
und wie sie nach buddhismus gekehrt sind
und was sie erlebt haben und wie sie
verführt und dann vermieden haben und so
weiter und so fort
es gibt ein interessantes buch darüber
das ist diese dieses buch von blackstone
die ganz unten ist auf der
literaturliste und sie wollte erforschen
dieser deckel interessant weil wir diese
dieses paar haben also dieses 2 bücher
so sagen die weibliche fassungen die
männliche fassen und sie wollte dann
erforschen was
wie verschieden sie sind
interessanterweise gibt es manchmal die
gleiche geschichten in beiden fassungen
einmal über einen berühmten manch einmal
über eine berühmte nonne also eine
geschichte die in beiden vorkommt ist
das also in der weiblichen fassung geht
eine frau die straße entlang und wird
nicht angegriffen aber ein mann kommt
und versucht sie zu verführen
und sie erklärt ihm dass das keine gute
idee es dadurch dass sie sagt der körper
ist nur ein sterbliche sda es wird
später faulen und mit gefüllt mit wärmer
sein und blablabla aber will sie er will
nicht abgelenkt werden und will
unbedingt mit ihr schlafen und deswegen
reist sie einen augen eine auge aus und
bietet es ihm an
und das funktioniert
und man könnte sagen ja ok typisch dass
es typisch also hier wie die typische
kommentar auf frauen aber die klar es
gibt die gleiche geschichte über einen
möchte oder eine eigens eine sehr
ähnliche geschichte in der männlichen
fasern trotzdem wie bitte nicht
attackiert aber er also irgendwie will
eine frau verführen oder sie hat
interesse an ihn und wenn nichts aus
gerettet werden bis er das macht weiß
nicht ob das papier seine auge ausweist
aber macht irgendwas ganz
beeindruckendes um hitze ab zu werden
blackstone aber argumentiert schon dass
wir eine viel stärkere betonung der
niedrigen werte des körper ist in der
verfassung wenn die frauen behandelt
also die idee scheint es ist ein fast
das internet fast ein bisschen an dieses
thema was wir oft in der in der
europäischen situation gefunden haben
frauen philosophie und frauen
philosophie ist zu lernen den körper zu
kontrollieren
vielleicht weil frauen angeblich
anfälliger sind von dem körper
beeinflusst zu werden also die karriere
lustig im kleinsten so gut halten und
deswegen muss ein text der für frauen
schwimmen würde immer wieder empfehlen
und beschreiben wie man müsste dann
irgendwie in maßen halten kann
eine interessante frage
die blackstone auch bespricht ist ob
dieser text von frauen geschrieben würde
das können wir nicht wissen natürlich
dass irgendwie naheliegend dass der text
vielleicht innerhalb einer weiblichen
gemeinde produziert würde weil es
offensichtlich an frauen gerichtet die
die der botschaft ist offenbar
dem beispiel an all diese frauen die wir
in den text beschreiben
allerdings angesichts der existenz der
die der anderen fassung für männer
könnte man vielleicht meinen nein männer
hatten das geschieht geschrieben für
beide ist das ein bisschen hand diese
briefe der der pseudo kategorische
briefe die auch angeblich von frauen
geschrieben wurden und auch für frauen
mit ethische beratung ist ähnlich in der
jane tradition gibt es sogar ein streit
darüber ob es möglich ist für frauen
überhaupt teilzunehmen an der natürlich
können können frauen jane klein werden
das ist das wird nicht in frage gestellt
die frage ist ob china frauen aufnehmen
werden dürfen die in buddhismus und hier
gibt es einen meinungsunterschied wie so
oft haben die janis dann gesplittet in
zwei gruppen die sogenannte himmels
bekleidete und die wayss verkleidete und
die ameise verkleidete hat einen weißen
mantel und die hermes verkleidete hatten
gar nichts
hörst du sie waren nachts und das gehört
zu ihrer askese vielleicht würde man
denken das klingt ganz schön und wahr
denn die insel herum surfen ohne kleider
nein aber immerhin wenn man daran denkt
du musst durch dein ganzes leben kommen
nicht ohne kleidung das ist natürlich
sehr sehr schwierig denken sie daran
manchmal ist winter
also wirklich eines der hts käse und sie
ja diese himmels bekleidete channels
haben dann entschieden dass frauen das
nicht machen können weil es zu
gefährlich ist
und das ist ein beispiel von dem was wir
erhofft in dieser befreiungs kultur
finden das unabhängig zu sein und aus
der gesellschaftlichen sicherheit zu
steigen war okay für männer aber nichts
für frauen weil es zu gefährlich weit
also ich glaube sehr wichtig in dieser
überlegung ist dass sie vergewaltigt
werden können
und wenn frauen so nacht durch die
gegend gehen haben sie gesagt sie werden
ständig attackiert und das können wir
tagen deswegen dürfen sie nicht
mitmachen
das ist eine unterscheidung innerhalb
der jane geschichte ok jetzt ein paar
beispiele und das jetzt für
philosophische etwas sparen für das
sollte etwas spannender über texte aus
der vedischen kultur oder hat jemand
fragen übrigens könnt ihr jetzt pause
machen
ich wurde angesprochen dass menschen den
kritischen münchen
gedanke dahinter ist dass man nicht
kochen kann ohne gewalt ausüben also
selbst selbst wenn man der gitarre
schlägt die nehmen das sehr ernst dass
man die pflanzen und bringen muss man
selbst das ist schlecht und dann gibt es
andere probleme
zum beispiel wenn man essen erntet oder
also wenn max bauer muss man schauen
dass die insekten die ente nichts
zerstört na ja ich komme zu dem ja ich
wollte das erklärt warum sie das machen
also die gedanke dahinter ist dass die
möchte kein hessen vorbereiten können
weil sie zu viel gewalt ausüben müssten
das ist sehr sehr stark in janis muss
aber auch im buddhismus und also die die
idee ist die laien bereiten das essen
vor
für sich und theoretisch haben sie das
nichts für die mönche gemacht und dann
kommen die mönche seien quatsch habt ihr
was übrig für mich und wenn dann möchte
das ist dann kann er das machen ohne in
dem gewalt mit beteiligt zu sein hat
aber betteln ist vielleicht ja irgendwie
schon
und natürlich haben sie diese betten
battle schütze ich glaube im normalen
fall werden sie auch erwartet also alle
wissen was passieren wird es nicht als
ob sie so seien unerwartet auftauchen
es ist schwierig weil sie meinen das
essen soll nichts für sie gedacht seien
mindestens theoretisch also irgendwie so
dass nicht alles geplant seine kleine im
normalen fall war es oft auch geplant
und die die laien bekommen auch was
dafür die die haben praktisch die die
leistung gemacht dass sie bei den
mönchen geholfen haben also alle
gewinnen
bitte ist eigentlich gut durchdacht
es gibt übrigens eine interessante frage
hier ob so sagen die die die böse des
gewalt irgendwie haut gesetzt wird
anhand der menschen und wie soll das
gehen wenn ich davon profitiere ich auch
nicht mitgeteilt und so weiter und das
ist eine interessante ethische frage die
auch innerhalb der koalition sehr auf
nachgefragt wird
die übrigens diese die vestische leute
haben auch wir von den texten bis an
diese leute sind sind so armen
schmutzige entstehen da mit dem
schlüssel oder sind es wirklich letzten
tja also die die haben wirklich es ist
nicht alle vielleicht aber wir finden
oft texte die wirklich diese leute
verspotten weil wegen des lebensstils
und dieses betteln gehört dazu es ist
ein teil der polemik von der bayerischen
seite gegen die buddhisten und chinas
gibt es weibliche philosophinnen in
antiken indien antwort vielleicht genau
wie im 1
also man könnte irgendwie mit sehr viel
betonung ja beantworten wenn man damit
meint es gibt es weibliche figuren die
in texten auftauchen und die als
philosophen vorgestellt wer oder
dargestellt werden
es wird mehrere beispiele
ich werde drei besprechen das erste
beispiel und das zweite beispiel auch
kommt aus die den brie hat daran
japanische hat er einige heißt große
wald und das geld zu den
interessantesten sowieso von der
philosophie her also wenn wenn man ein
japanischer art lesen will und das ist
etwas was für philosophische inhalt hat
ich würde ihm entweder das entfernen
oder die shanti yoga japanisch hat oder
beides aber ihr habt das ausgewählt weil
wir zwei beispiele in dem text haben von
genannten frauen die im philosophischen
gespräch auftauchen und in beiden fällen
kommt das vor in einer szene wo
einbrachen philosoph priester kommen
philosoph paar mitgeteilt ist oder heißt
ja genial wird ja und der slowakei ist
ein interessanter ist anscheinend eine
schlüsselfigur in der entwicklung der
japanischen philosophie diese es jetzt
mehrere sehr berühmte passagen wo eine
theorie dass selbst erklärt wird es sind
mit ihm irgendwie verbunden also erst
der sprecher in dieser szene
nur kreuz ein bisschen mehr über den
dänen panische an zu sagen wieso ihm
gesagt habe sie sind sehr verschieden
und man kann nicht pauschal sagen was in
allen palisaden vorkommt aber in den
szenen die uns interessieren und in
vielen anderen senden
die scheinen fast eine art ist das
internet sehr sehr in eine platonische
dialog es gibt mehrere figuren und die
sitzen zusammen oft am hof eines königs
und argumentieren gegen sie einander
normalerweise ohne ausführliche
argumente die in plateau also niemand
wird das werden sie gleich sehen
ich werde ein typisches beispiel
vorlesen aber es nicht als ob wir sehr
detaillierte ausgelegte philosophie
argumente haben
allerdings kann das später mit der
vedanta schule also in der pension gibt
es schon aber die idee dass man
grundlegende wahrheit tiefere wahrheit
als die wahrheit die die meisten
menschen erkennen können dass man das
durch einer philosophischen dialog
darstellen könnte dass wenn wir auch in
den japanischen sehr sehr stark und
unser erstes beispiel kommt aus einer
szene in dieser in diesem panischer
sozialwerke und mehreren wäre die andere
philosophen am hof eines königs
zusammensitzen der könig heißt jana k
und k k das kommt auch auf vor in dem
fall hat ein kreis bereits vorbereitet
für den tasten bratman also der weiseste
brachten der kommt also der beste
priester praktisch der die die das
tiefstes verständnis hat vielleicht
und der preis ist was auch relativ auch
vorkommt also es gibt diese kühe und
dann kommen all diese priester mann
heißt es nicht von ganz weit weg sie zu
sammeln sich am hof und dann sagt der
könig der weißeste von euch soll die
kühe wegführen
und die sind alle ein bisschen
schüchtern bis jetzt ja wie gesagt ich
nehme sie gefällt sein seinen diener die
tour wechsel führen und alle anderen
beamten sind empört sagen hey wieso bist
du der beste und er ist sagt praktisch
fragt mich was ihr wollt und ich zeige
euch wie weise ich bin gegen das geht
dann weiter die stellen praktisch sagt
sind fast wie philosophische räten die
er beantworten muss also was ist die
bedeutung dieser ritual oder wie es in
die grotte in dieser hinsicht blablabla
ja beantwortet ist als und dann im
dritten kapitel kommt unerwartet eine
frau voll und das liest sich als ob sie
einfach eine von den brachten es die
anwesen ist es gibt überhaupt keine
erklärung warum ist sie weiblich ist
oder warum sie da ist sie ist nur da und
ist es klar dass sie eine frau ist
dass sie heißt kg vac navi und stellt
ihn eine reihe von fragen die gleich
vorlesen würde und sie wird nicht
widerlegt aber genial wirklich sagt
praktisch höher auf diesen wenn und dann
schweiz sie übrigens bei jedem austausch
ist es so dass eine reihe von fragen
wird von
am anderen brachmann gestellt slavia
prag an alles beantworten und dann
schweigt der andere sagt er und dann ist
dann hat er geschwiegen oder dann ist er
weg gegangen
und das passiert auch bei ihr ist die
schweiz aber in ihrem fall nach zwei
seiten taucht sie wieder auf und stellt
mehrere wenn ich die clark die gleiche
frage und wird wieder beantwortet und
dann sagt sie
hier sollte anerkennen dass er der beste
ist von euch
er gewinnt ihr konnten ihn nicht
besiegen
es ist wirklich interessant dass sie
nicht nur zweimal vorkommt aber auch
diejenige ist die ihn als sieger erklärt
ok wollen sie das hören wie das kind
gespannt ok also hier ist der erste satz
bulgari vorkommt darauf begann gar die
weltwirtschaft nach ihm fragen zu
stellen
da wird ja sagte sie wenn das ganze an
wie ein faden unterhalb und oberhalb des
wassers als träger aufgezogen ist
unterhalb und oberhalb davon als träger
ist denn dann das wasser aufgezogen also
worauf stürzt das wasser also die frage
auf den wind kg unterhalb und oberhalb
nur von als träger ist dann ist denn
dann der will darf gezogen
auf den raum magie das können schon
voraussehen was sie schlagen wird
unterhalb und oberhalb von als träger
ist denn dann der raum aufgezogen auf
den rahmen zwischen erde und firmament
kg und haben oberhalb wovon als träger
ist denn dann der raum zwischen erde und
firmament aufgezogen auf die bereiche
des himmels kg und so weiter es geht
dann durch himmel sonne mond und gott
und dann fragt sie unterhalb und
oberhalb von als träger sind denn dann
die bereiche der götter aufgezogen auf
die bereiche der kanaren also weitere
gestanden worauf ist das gezogen
die bereiche property security ist ein
vater gott dann und dann sagt sie worauf
es bei gewitter aufgezogen auf die
bereiche des baugrunds kg und dann fragt
sie unterhalb und oberhalb wovon sind
denn die bereiche des burgund aufgezogen
und dann sagt er
kg 2 wäre es nicht zu weit mit dem
fragen dass dir dein kopf nicht bersten
du gehst mit deiner frage über einen
markt hinaus über die hinaus man nicht
weiter fragen kann
kg treibe es nicht soweit mit dem
schlagen daraufhin verstummte gabi
werkzeug navi bevor ich das dann ich
versuche das dann wurde dann kurz 22 die
passage lesen sie kommt wieder und
stellt mehrere fragen und dann sagt sie
sozialwerke unterhalt unterhalt wovon
als träger ist das aufgezogen was
oberhalb des firmaments günther hat der
erde war es zwischen firmament und erde
hier ist und was man vergangenen
gegenwärtig und zukünftig netz er
antwortete kg was gruppe hat das
finanzproblem bla bla bla bla nennt ist
unterhalb ein oberhalb des raums in
seinem träger abgezogen also die gleiche
antwort die er vorher angeboten hat und
dann ist sie wieder was ist der träger
des raums und dann sagt er dass das
alles ausbleibende rot daher ein
ungewisses bleiben wenn er erklärt dass
das bleibende so dass es weder groben
auch feine wird er kurz noch lang weder
blut noch fett hat keinen glanz und
keine finsternis ohne wind und raum und
so weiter und so fort
es kommt dann niemanden
niemand kommt hannes heran dieses
bleibende gabi ist ergänzt des sehens
der selbst nicht gesehen wird ist agents
des hörens dass sie selbst nicht gehört
wird ist ergänzte des denkens deshalb
nicht gegenstand des denkens ist ist
agent des erkennens das selbst nicht
gegenstand des erkennens ist es gibt
keinen anbieter ergänzte sehen es kein
anderer ergänzt es für uns keinen
anderen agents des denkens keinen
anderen agents des erkennens es ist
dieses bleibende als träger kg unterhalb
und oberhalb dessen der raum aufgezogen
ist da sagte sie planen ihr herren ihr
solltet euch erfolgreich schätzen wenn
ihr dem da mit einem bloßen gruß
entkommen könnt es wird gewiss niemand
von euch ihn in einem disput über wenden
daraufhin verstummte die vag navi es ist
interessant wie gesagt dass sie
diejenige ist die ihn als sieger erklärt
was ist hier los
philosophisch was hier los ist ist ein
versuch immer grundlegende prinzipien zu
definieren und die fangen mit ganz
konkreten sachen zum beispiel wasser
wind erde kommen dann auf himmelskörper
sonne mond und dann auf sehr abstrakte
dinge in der ersten passage das
abstrakte dinge dass das erste abstrakte
und dann geht es richtung lotte also
sagen es wird philosophisch und dann
wird es plötzlich wieder das könnte man
sagen geht durch einen reifen gott und
dann kommt auf ein unbestimmtes urgrund
und wenn sie für nachfragt was ist was
ist die was ist fundament für diese
urgrund sagt er ja wirklich fragen nicht
weiter als du fragst zu viel und da ist
kann man das natürlich sehr verschieden
auslegen
vielleicht gibt es weitere antwort die
ergeben könnte aber sie ist nicht bereit
dafür
vielleicht weiß er selber nicht was er
sagen soll oder vielleicht ist der punkt
nach einer gewissen es gibt all diese
ketten in dieser causa
und wenn man das ende erreicht ist es
ein fehler nachzufragen was da was
weiter kommt also man kann nicht immer
immer wieder fragen wie ein vierjähriger
warum warum warum es muss am ende ein
einen grund geben und in der ersten
passage ist das sehr unbefriedigendes
nur als urgrund definiert wird und gar
geht zeigt sich als bin zufrieden und
sagt ja ok aber
was ist das was mir erklären was
die würde diesen auf der gründe
verstehen sollen
und dann kommt ja wie kann mit seiner
typischen charakteristischen theorie
der grund ist dass selbst das ist dass
die bewusst des bewusstseins lights was
hinter alle erfahrungen steht also
hinter sehen hinter her kennen also 1 1
die aktivität vielleicht eine
subjektivität die die vor jeder
erfahrung kommen kann und das ist eine
idee die dann sehr weit weiter
weiterentwicklung dann in der spätere
installation hat zum beispiel den winter
haben wir die theorie eines selbst es
auch brachmann genannt werden kann was
der welt gegenüber gestellt wird das ist
praktisch eine ausarbeitung von dem was
national werke seien in dem zweiten
beispiel sagt ja was sehr ähnliches und
es hilft uns das besser zu verstehen
hier haben wir eine szene die
anscheinend zu hause bei schönem wetter
passiert denn ist ein mit
gesprächspartner ist seine frau
es wird erst gesagt dass er zwei frauen
hat und die eine frau meint ray hat
interesse eine philosophische themen und
ist deswegen ihm lieber als die andere
frau die sich nur mit frauen sachen
beschäftigt wie es in dem text steht und
sie fragt und es ist sehr interessant
sie fragt ihn wie sie unsterblich werden
kann
das ist interessant weil man
normalerweise in der bayerischen
koalition erwartet dass der ehemann
versucht unsterblich zu werden durch
rituale und sie sagt praktisch aber was
ist mit mir
wie kann ich unsterblich werden und dann
erklärt er
dass die grob gesagt schon sowieso
unsterblich ist weil sie nur ein selbst
ist der hinter alle ihren erfahrungen
steht und nicht mit dem körperlichen
existenz so effizient ist und dieser
selbst kann von einem leben bis zum
nächsten dann überleben also warum
praktisch die gleiche theorie aber hier
eingesetzt und so sollen diakonische
diakonisches leben also von einem leben
zum nächsten so erklären
übrigens in klammern ein haupt streit
zwischen gästen und meisten von diesen
philosophen ist dass die buddhisten
natürlich die existenz eines selbst
völlig abgelehnt haben
also wir haben wir eine sehr starke
unterscheidung zwischen der stahlwerker
und alles was nach ihm kommt in der
vegetation eine immer bleibendes ein
immer bleiben dass selbst unveränderlich
vor allen erfahrungen und die buddhisten
die lernen das ist überhaupt kein salz
gibt und dann gibt es positionen in der
mitte also zum beispiel manche von
diesen schulen lernen dass wir ein
empirisches selbst haben aber kein
selbst das 2 1 in den tests wie hier sei
welcher hier war behauptet ok also dass
es so sagen viele solche inhalt dieser
passagen offensichtliche frage warum
sind hier zwei frauen
warum müssen dass zwei frauen die
gewählt werden als figuren um diese
theorie zu profitieren und die antwort
ist nochmal unklar
nein natürlich könnte man sagen dass wir
das als ein hinweis nehmen dass es
wirklich brach manische frauen gab die
mitgeteilt worden einen philosophischen
gesprächen zum beispiel am hof und das
würde ich auch also das finde ich hier
plausibel in diesem fall weil wie gesagt
der text macht eigentlich kein ding
daraus dass kg eine frau ist und man
könnte davon entnehmen das ist irgendwie
historisch plausibel war für den leser
dass eine frau auch dabei war also nicht
als ob der text zum beispiel versucht zu
erklären wie es sein konnte dass auch
eine frau die da war im fall von von der
zweiten szene ist wahrscheinlich wichtig
dass das seine ehefrau ist und dass sie
sehr also relativ gleich sind dass sie
beide interesse an unsterblichkeit haben
trotzdem ist er der lehrer und cs die
lehrling das lernen aber immerhin könnte
das an sich zu fragen warum eine
möglichkeit ist aber dass die dass
frauen hier vorkommen
gerade weil der die autoren zeigen
wollen dass das innovativ ist und dass
das irgendwie eine kritik der früheren
vedischen annahmen war er ist egal
welcher was er lehrt ist wirklich neu
was er sagt ist okay ritual gut aber das
wichtigste ist diese philosophie die
theorie dass selbst und das bringt ja
sozusagen in die tradition rein und
vielleicht das als neue und vielleicht
sogar als eine kritik zu markieren
kommen dann diese außenseiter und beste
außenseite aller zeiten in dieser kultur
werde eine frau also dass eine frau dann
mitgeteilt es an diese zellen markiert
die zähne als einen fortschritt oder
eine so ein neuer botschaft innerhalb
der division und diese vermutung wird
dadurch gestärkt dass wir ein ähnlich
ein viel stärkeres beispiel haben einer
weiblichen kritik und das kommt in einer
passage aus denen nachher baratta wieder
mit knacker und hier ist jana k also in
mindestens der gleichen namen wirklich
könig damit gemeint ist aber das 1 1 er
ein könig der noch weiterhin als könig
lebt also regiert immer noch und
behauptet morscher und reich zu haben
also erst befreit
obwohl kein hat nicht als 90 lebt nicht
im wald mit arm harris immer noch reich
und so weiter aber behauptet dass er
befreit würde durch sein wissen
da hatte der und dann hört also ein
schwamm einer frau namens soll aber von
dieser behauptung
und sie ist anscheinend eine weise eine
art weise frau mit magischen yoga kräfte
sie benutzt ihre kräfte sich als
bildhübsche frau in eine bildhübsche
frau zu verwandeln wirklich und dann
teleportiert sie an das hof des königs
sie spart zeit damit
und dann nachdem er sie empfängt und
sagt du bist so schön
geht sie in seinen geist mit ihrem geist
und führt eine debatte mit ihm in so
sagen in seinem kopf oder in ihrem in
seinem geist und fragt ihn praktisch wie
erklär mir wie du das geschafft hast
dich zu befreien ohne ohne sozusagen aus
der aus diesem geschäft wir leben so
steigen
daher sagt na ja das geht schon solang
man kein verlangen hat dass das was man
tut irgendwas bringt also man das
befreit
man agiert in der welt weiter mannes
befreit davon interesse daran zu haben
ob das was man tut wirklich was bringt
also mann handelt ohne sorgen zu machen
ob das die handlung erfolgreich ist und
wenn man das versteht kann man befreit
sein
das ist interessant war dass genau die
theorie des handelns ist die hier in dem
bagger twitter finden das genau was
krishna als schöner sei es soll kämpfen
aber keine sorge machen was aus dem
kampf wird und das ist auch in den
machtapparat also man würde erwarten
dass zu labor an das zustimmen würde
aber bevor ich sie spricht geht herr
weiter mit dir mit ihrem it er geht
weiter mit seiner rede und sagte und
übrigens wer bist du dass du hergekommen
bist und in mein geist reingekommen und
praktisch meine privatsphäre
eingestiegen ist das ist gerade freiheit
ich weiß nicht wer du bist du könntest
jede aus jeder schicht kommen
du bist nur eine frau bla bla bla und
mach sie fertig praktisch und beleidigt
sie und dann antwortet sie und sie sagt
mehr oder weniger wenn du wirklich
befreit wärst würdest du solche sachen
gar nicht erwähnen weil wenn du wissen
hättest würdest du wissen dass es völlig
egal ist ob ich eine frau bin oder
äußerlich an ulreich bin alles was zählt
ist unser selbst als praktisch wer
welches ähnlich zu der theorie die wir
beim jahrgang der stahlwerker finden und
und damit gewinnt sie praktisch die
debatte gegen dellacqua und danach der
erzähler von der geschichte sagt nun sie
hat gut gesprochen
also sie will auch hier wird die frau
als siegerin erklärt
okay noch mal könnte was ist noch das
ist also wie knapp wir können davon
ausgehen dass keine frau teleportieren
konnte oder in den geist ein könig eines
königs die beiden stürzen konnte aber
trotzdem könnt ihr können wir vielleicht
historisches datum daraus bekommen
nämlich es gab auch anscheinend
weibliche nicht nennen aber warnende
weise frauen die dann in der lage waren
solche debatten zu führen vielleicht
aber an vielleicht wichtiger also nicht
so denn aufhören aber wichtiger ist zu
bemerken dass nochmal eine kritik gegen
eine traditionelle idee nämlich die idee
die wir in bayern aka finden was auch in
der bawag etat ist diese kritik wird
eine frau zugeschrieben
genau als damit das als kritik markiert
ist
und ich glaube das ist nichts das ist
kein versehen
man könnte sagen ein eine strategie eine
theorie system die wirklich
problematisch ist oder neu ist das
erreichen sie teilweise dadurch dass
eine frau als sprecherin vorkommt und
deswegen hat ein forscher darüber
geschrieben dass die anwesenheit der
frauen in diesem sinne ist das lesen auf
englisch vor wir sind interne kritik auf
den einlass um reflexion historiker die
also hat nichts mit historische
wirklichkeit zu tun hat damit zu tun
dass wir hier eine kritik der
dramatischen weltanschauung zu tun haben
fragen schnell da müssen wir wissen wann
das geschrieben würde also vor christus
auf jeden fall werde der jahrhundert vor
christus also machbar würde
wahrscheinlich über hunderte von jahren
geschrieben also man müsste fachleute
fragen wann genau diese passage
vielleicht geschrieben wurde es sowieso
sehr umstritten
also wissen nicht aber vor chris meyer
jahrhundert vor christus
ok
wir sind uns zwei wochen und dann werde
ich die mittelalterliche kulturen
vorstellen
im allgemeinen bis ans islam und latein
christentum und danach werden wir hoffen
dass lateinischen mittelalters
kennenlernen
o